كان من الصعب أن تصبح أكثر قبحًا ولكن كل
فجر لا تزال معركة من أجل
مطاحن كبيرة في
أوكرانيا يوم الإثنين قالت إنها دفعت
القوات الروسية للتراجع التي تخلت عن
أشهر من القتال المؤلم من أجل
ملعب كرة قدم كل يوم يقول المحللون
[تصفيق]
الجرحى الروس هنا
قال الجنود المهجورون هناك
كان هناك رجل يرقد هناك في
ريدز يقول إن رجال الشفاء يأتون ويساعدونني
لمدة ثلاثة أيام فقط 100 ياردة من
الروس
يخرجون أيضًا على طريق
الحياة هذا آخر طريق داخل وخارج
أخبار المدينة عن وفاة كوبر هاريس
أندروز في السادسة والعشرين من العمر ، وهو جندي سابق في مشاة البحرية الأمريكية ورجل
إطفاء من كليفلاند أوهايو ، شعر بأنه
مضطر للانضمام إلى معركة أوكرانيا ،
أراد كوبر تصحيح الأشياء التي أجرينا
الكثير من المحادثات حول الموضة التي
اعتدت أن أقولها كوبر ، وهذا يعني أنك "
أذهب إلى هناك لقيادة
سيارة إسعاف ،
والآن أنت
لا تؤمن بالأشياء التي تحبها ،
افعل شيئًا حيال ذلك ، من الواضح ، دعونا
نصنع صورة لتاريخنا هنا ، إنه
بالقرب من خط المواجهة في يناير
كجزء من الفيلق الأجنبي الموصوف  نظرًا لأن
جسده أيديولوجي حتى النخاع ومناهض للاستبداد ، لم يتم استرداد جسده بعد
من باكموت لأن القتال
كان شديدًا للغاية ، تذكرت والدته
آخر مرة تحدثوا فيها ، هل
يمكن أن ترسل لي
صلصة حارة وشرائح
[ضحك]
لذلك أنا مثل
منزلي  لأنني كنت أحاول الحصول على
أعواد للعجول لكل شخص ، كنت أظن الأشخاص الذين
لديهم متاجر ولدي كل هذه
الحزم الصغيرة من
الصلصة الحارة
التي كنت سأرسلها إلى Cooper
خلال الأسابيع الماضية ،
ظهرت لقطات معركة مصورة توضح
كيف يبدو الأمر عندما يدخل الروس
شبكة خنادق أوكرانية
هنا جندي يهرع للغطاء
قريبًا تسقط قذيفة ،
كلهم ​​بخير بأعجوبة ولكن
الهجوم بدأ
يراقب وترى نهجًا روسيًا
ورمي قنبلة يدوية
أخطأها
سأستمر في إسقاط الروس الذين
يتقدمون على بعد أمتار من
استمرت قذائفهم في الهبوط ،
واستمر الهجوم لأكثر من 10 دقائق ، لكن
القتال المكسور لـ Bachman يستمر ويستمر